After speaking with so many Iranian-Americans for this series, I still had one more question.
"What do people get wrong about L.A.'s Iranian-American community?"
“We only get a few faces: terrorist, kitschy or campy…”
“A stereotype is that we’re very lavish, lavish parties, lavish decorating…”
“The gaudy, the rich…”
“But we don’t get to be our whole selves, real people.”
“When I left Los Angeles, I really began to realize that in the rest of the U.S.,
most people don’t know anything about Iranians.
And for them, Iranians are total strangers that they see on TV that are angry
and burning things and chanting ‘death to America.’”
“The Muslim world, we’re not just all violent or terrorist people.”
“All they heard about Iran was ‘terrorist.’”
“Obviously, our community is sort of negotiating stereotypes between either Argo,
or, you know, we have 300…”
“Shahs of Sunset.”
“That was the last one I was going to mention.”
“The Shahs of Sunset.”
“This season on Shahs of Sunset…”
[screaming]
“More attitude!”
“Ladies, you're in my shot!
It’s my birthday!”
“I’ve never related to those stereotypes.”
“For Iranians, it’s become so humiliating. That’s the only thing they’re associated with.
And it’s not like that doesn’t exist – I always say, it does exist –
but there’s so much more than that.”
“The Shahs of Sunset, I love that show.
Hey, let Americans see that we can party too! Let them see Iranians are fun people –
they bring a tiger to the party!”
“L.A.’s Iranian community is incredibly diverse.”
“Persians are very deep people – they’re very poetic, they’re very kind.”
“We are Iranian. We’re just like everybody else.”
“I’ve been here since I was three and I’m a practicing attorney.”
“Every one of our ethnic as well as religious minorities are well represented here.
We do have a large Armenian community, a large Bahá'í community, a large Jewish community...”
“...every single class, of every certain interest, and vocation, and gender, sexuality…”
“What people get wrong the most – they associate Iranians with money.
There is a wealthy population but most of us do not have money and we've very much
had to struggle to survive in California.”
“How do you identify yourself in terms of Iranian-American, Persian-American, Persian-Iranian?
What kind of language do you use?”
“I say Persian because that’s what I heard, growing up as a kid.”
“It’s a very complicated question.”
“Most people who hear the word ‘Persian’ don't actually even know what it means.
I think Persian just sounds like something exotic, and they don’t even realize it is Iran.”
“So I think a lot of people, maybe first-generation folks who might have immigrated here,
and perhaps doesn't want to use the term Iranian.
But we can reclaim that and repurpose it and be like – and make it cool.”
“For me being Iranian isn’t just my connection to that country, but being Iranian
is also about being a part of this mosaic of cultures in this country.
Having people know that I'm Iranian is an important thing for me.
Partially because, at this moment in time, we are so discriminated against.
People feel like they have no image what an Iranian is
and they can’t even imagine meeting one.
I think it's important to represent Iranians and to point out they are also doing all these other things too."
You just watched the last video in our "Untold America" series about Iranian-Americans.
Make sure you watch the first three videos in the series too.
There's breakdancing, Persian ice cream, videos of me as a baby -- it's definitely worth it.
Also, we have another great AJ+ explainer channel called "Because Facts" so make sure
to check them out too. And let us know what stories you want "Untold America" to cover next.